CBS this morning is partnered with
professional networking site LinkedIn
for our continuing series work in
progress we're exploring the future of
jobs and issues facing the American
workforce we are looking this morning at
the growing number of job openings in
the u.s. the latest labor statistics
show the number of job openings rose to
more than 6 million in April that's an
all-time high by the way that's up more
than 7% from the same time a year ago
LinkedIn CEO Jeff Weiner is with us at
the table to discuss the numbers hello
Jeff Fleener
before we do that I know you heard the
overnight news about Travis kalanick
officially resigning how big a deal is
it and what message does it send because
last week we heard he was going to take
a temporary leave of absence and now he
stepped down this is huge yeah it's a
big deal it's a big deal for a number of
reasons not the least of which the share
of mine that Hoover occupies in terms of
consumers and transportation
infrastructure you know this is Travis's
company he created it he's the
controlling shareholder my understanding
is he's still going to remain on the
board and it'll be very interesting to
see how they handle the transition from
this point but it looks like or appear
that it happened the resignation because
of pressure from the investors that he
brought in yeah that's my understanding
as well and I think it speaks to some of
the challenges that the company's been
experiencing the fact that the investors
felt like that with the necessary staff
in order to ensure the success of the
company going forward well there's an
opening if there ever was a time for
compassionate leadership which you are
known for Jeff Weiner I'm very happy in
my current role and I wish the new CEO
whoever that is the best what do you
think the new CEO needs to do a few
different things given the the situation
that they're going to be walking into
one recognizing that with Travis stone
remaining on the board the founder of a
company cast a very long shadow
regardless of who that person is so
establishing the right relationship with
Travis is going to be essential I think
second is you could argue that changing
culture is the single most difficult
thing you can do to a company or an
operation and so remaining patient
managing expectations and understanding
how big that challenges and third is an
old friend once told me trust equals
consistency over time and it's a simple
formula for a complex human dynamic
and I think it's really important that
whoever steps into that situation is
going to be very consistent with what it
is that they're trying to accomplish and
be patient I interview Jack ma last
night and that's one thing he said trust
trust truth has to be exist let me turn
to the jobs yeah and the question too
many people would like to ask you where
are they so in terms of some of the
cities with the fastest growing influx
of talent which I think in to some
extent is a reflection or a proxy for
where those job opportunities are we're
seeing a lot of growth and a lot of
movement cities like Seattle Portland
Denver Austin Charlotte all tech centers
increasingly tech centers very high
quality of living and by comparison with
an area like Silicon Valley lower cost
of living although that is changing as
you see more and more people going to
these cities but six million openings
Jeff all-time-high why is that now yeah
it's it's really interesting to see six
million available jobs Gail exactly to
your point that's the highest number
they've seen on record since tracking
the data like this specifically you know
there's a lot of to paint back and forth
among economists is there a skill gap is
there not a skill gap I think when you
think about it in the aggregate across
the United States you can debate it but
unquestionably at the local level there
are skills gaps there are cities that
are hiring they're hiring quickly
they've got fast-growing industries and
they don't have the talent with the
requisite skills to take on those roles
and so what LinkedIn would like to do is
leverage all this extraordinary data
we've been able to collect by virtue of
having 500 million people join the site
we have over 10 million jobs that are
now listed on the site 50,000
standardized skills we've got the
information to match talent to jobs in a
way that was never possible before so
we're really going to put it together
the jobs with the person that's the the
ultimate goal charlie is to make sure
that each individual member has
information about where those jobs are
the skills required to obtain the jobs
and ideally even be able to acquire
those skills either on or off of
LinkedIn to obtain the job for employers
it's an understanding of what skills
they're going to need to be able to
continue to grow and where that talent
exists and we'd also like to be able to
provide this information to governments
and educational infrastructure junior
colleges vocational training facilities
to create ideally just-in-time
curriculum but you recently said a
company meeting skills not degrees is
what you're looking for is someone whose
son just recently graduated from
Business School what Oh what does that
mean do you think degrees are not as
important so I think coming back to the
skills not degrees what you're Jeff yeah
first I wouldn't characterize it as
skills not degrees I think sometimes
people hear us talking about the
importance of skills and not to overlook
skills and that skills and degrees are
not mutually exclusive I think sometimes
they like to take headlines and make
that a bit provocative exactly to your
point there are people pursuing degrees
graduating with degrees that are
incredibly valuable some of these people
they're first generation and their
families to be able to graduate college
and they're gonna go on to jobs that
their parents couldn't have dreamed up
that said certainly speaking for Silicon
Valley we do too much hiring based on
traditional backgrounds and traditional
education and we are overlooking
incredible talent that may not have the
prestigious degree but has the
resilience the grit the perseverance the
growth mindset to that point can the
next there's been a lot of talk about
this whether whether the current
generation can be more successful than
their parents which has always been the
Assumption in American life right that
the kid that the children do better what
what challenges do you see on that front
for for the next generations I think one
of the biggest challenges is going to be
education and acquiring the right skill
set to take advantage of the
opportunities that are and will be and
not just the jobs that once were and you
have a lot of these kinds of spent
enormous amounts of money on degrees and
aren't getting jobs yes and aren't
getting jobs that pay well at all yeah
so what we do oh you go ahead yeah so
again I think it comes back to making
sure we understand where those job
opportunities are going back to the six
million jobs that are available in the
country today when you have the data and
understand where those jobs are the
skills that are required for those jobs
and you can help people better match
their own skills to those opportunities
I think we can start to close that gap
but to your point there is a lot of pain
out there there is a lot of anger out
there and that's one of the reasons
we're working together on work in
progress is to shine a light on some of
those stories so that people understand
where there's fear in this country about
being displaced by virtue of Technology
where the jobs are leaving where the
jobs
- and we're grateful to be working with
you guys on that let me make one quick
point which everybody agrees with you
know it's important to be able to find
jobs and have the skills that come with
finding a job or they get you the job
it's also important to have a good
liberal education going to college is
not just about finding a job it's about
understanding you know the civilization
understanding where you come from and
understanding and getting other kinds of
skills that will benefit you as a human
being
it absolutely is again I don't think
this is mutually exclusive Steve Jobs
used to talk about the importance of a
liberal arts education and connecting
dots and it was those connection of dots
that enabled him to create Apple and
some of the brilliant innovation that
Apple's introduced to the world the
flipside charlie is that frankly our
universities our school system is not
doing a good enough job equipping people
with the skills they need for the jobs
that are and will be as opposed to the
jobs that want thanks yeah great ahead
great to be here very say quickly Jobs
was kicked out of Apple II think killing
it you think killing it goes back to
over at some points I it'll be really
interesting to keep an eye on that and
see whether or not it happens we are all
watching thank you Jeff Lena